So today, uh, we- we're welcoming two accomplished speakers,
as I said, Anand Subramani and Jiaona Zhang.
Uh, both of them have extensive experience in Product Management,
as well as extensive experience as teachers of Product Management.
They run a very successful class here at Stanford, uh,
for the past few years,
and they are going to be offering it for the first time,
this winter, to, uh, community members,
local and remote, who want to attend in person or, uh, or online.
Rather than giving an extensive introduction,
I'm going to turn it over to them to tell- talk about
their path to product management and then move into their presentation on,
uh, the product life cycle.
Great. Thank you, Pax. Uh, hi everyone.
Thank you again for joining us today.
My name is Anand Subramani, like Pax mentioned.
Um, a little bit about my background before we jump to the material themselves.
So, um, I'm currently the VP of Product at a start-up called
Pilot that build some software automated bookkeeping and tax preparation.
Um, I spent most of my career after school in product management itself.
Um, I did my undergraduate and my grad both at Stanford,
so it's nice to be coming home again.
Um, after I graduated,
I ended up in product management leadership roles at companies like Gusto,
and Dropbox, and Zynga.
Um, I spent a vast majority of my career,
like I mentioned, in product management since I left school.
I'm very excited to share a little bit about what we're going today with you.
Cool. So hey guys,
I am JZ. I'm currently a Director of Products at WeWork and before that,
I was, um, at Airbnb for four years.
Anand and I actually met at Dropbox, um,
where we got a lot of collaboration class together, and Dropbox for business.
Anand and I started my career in, uh,
product management actually pretty similar- similarly,
uh, worked in consulting and then moved over to gaming.
And so it's a mobile gaming company called Pocket Gems.
So that's a little bit about us.
Um, we wanted to talk today about two really large focus areas.
One of the most common questions that we get, uh,
both from students as well as people who are not PM is,
tell me a little bit about the job.
Um, and, what does it actually mean?
What does the day-to-day look like?
Um, I'm potentially interested in making
a career transition or I'm interested in breaking to the field.
So I actually start out there.
What is the responsibility of the product manager?
Um, one thing to note is that our lived experience has been
the job of a product manager can vary widely based on company to company.
Um, even in company in similar sectors or
company that's somewhere from an outside perspective,
there are very different concepts of what it means actually to be a product manager.
So we tried to find some of the patterns in our class around things we believe are true
across all companies rather than focus on the variant in individual companies.
And our take is merely for primary jobs of a product manager at any organization.
Um, the first is all about setting the vision for the product.
And this is probably something that many of you might have heard.
You might have heard the phrase, you're often the CEO of your product,
and I think that's definitely true.
You are fundamentally taking the path that your team is gonna walk on.
And early in your career,
you probably will not spend a lot of the time doing this.
You, uh, become a junior product manager or an associate product manager,
but as you get more senior,
more and more of your job actually become this.
A great example of what it means to set a vision.
Uh, one of our favorite case studies for the class is actually Amazon.
Um, the example that we get a lot
is that the company started off by selling books on the Internet,
but it was very clear that the boundaries and
the product leaders knew what they wanted in the long term.
They wanted to be a place where you can buy anything online, uh,
and they started with books and they had
a very grand plan to go from books to everything.
Um, so this is a little bit of a,
uh, concrete example to help to make that real for you.
But one of the things we've seen across every company and across every industry,
it's your job as a product leader is to
figure out the vision for your products and your team.
One thing maybe just to add is, you know,
you have usually a company vision,
maybe an organization vision.
It's your job to really translate that into what does
it actually mean for your team and where they need to work on.
Definitely. The second thing that would be
a really common responsibility across
all product managers is about managing some portfolio projects.
And again, this transition is a little bit as you
start off junior and become more senior,
but fundamentally, almost always managing more than one thing.
And a big part of your job is to put together
a coherent set of projects that ladder up to something more.
Um, it's not about the next feature,
it's not about the next iteration,
it's about trying to create something useful
and functional from a customer perspective where
all of the individual pieces to actually connect to form
something larger than the whole Um, so we see this a  lot.
This is not a really common question to get.
Uh, from a life cycle perspective,
you tend to do more of this as well as you get more senior.
Um, but we wanted to call it out as one of the core responsibilities that we see as product managers.
Um, the third one which we notice to be common across every industry is,
you actually have to ship stuff.
It is, uh, surprisingly common to be
really good at the first to maybe less good at this one,
but you can't actually build things and deliver things to the customer.
It doesn't matter how good your at strategy,
doesn't matter how good you are at thinking projects,
you fundamentally haven't delivered anything of value to your customers.
So a huge component of being a product manager is actually shipping things on time,
high quality, and well.
Um, so we'll focus a lot on this in the actual class.
If anybody's interested in the future about how to actually
ship things online and how to deliver products to people.
But if you are not actually delivering anything,
it is impossible for you to be responsible for others.
Another thing caught here is that shipping is not
just about program management or product management,
like keeping the, you know, train running.
It's a lot about how do you know what outcome you want to achieve,
how do you make make sure that the team cross
the finish line and have the impact that you're looking for.
And then finally, um, one of
the core responsibilities of
a product manager is all about managing the product life cycle.
This is actually going to be the focus of the webinar today and it looks like,
uh, one of the reasons that a lot of great part of these people were here.
Um, so I'll turn it over to JZ to introduce the notion of a product life cycle.
Um, and we'll spend a little bit of time going through more details.
Awesome.
Okay. So excited that a lot of you here are hoping to learn more,
uh, which, I mean, is the point of this webinar today.
So this slide basically shows an overview of what we call the Product Life cycle.
And so I'll go to each one and talk a little bit about what does that actually mean,
and what you need to consider in that particular phase of the life cycle.
So overall, the product life cycle is simple a framework.
It's a framework for you to actually take an idea from scratch,
from something where it's just a problem for
your users and actually build something that solves that problem for them.
One of the things we want to emphasize here that our belief is that this is very
much a generic problem-solving framework that is not specific to a type of company.
Whether you're making software,
whether you're making hardware or whether you're
a 10,000 person company and whether they are a 50-person company,
you're going to do some form of this in all stages.
The amount you'll spend will vary,
the amount of effort you have to put out will vary,
but I would not think of this as being associated with, you know,
a specifics for a product or specific labor of product management,
it's a generic framework from our perspective how we deal with these things.
Certainly.
All right. So the first for the product life cycle is,
um, called evaluating of opportunities.
So it's really about making sure that you understand
what problem you're trying to solve and why is it an opportunity.
And so there's two parts to stress.
The first is, you need to figure out a real need and a problem for your users.
And the second part, the part about the opportunity,
is that you have to believe that there is
an opportunity for generating value for your business.
And so a lot of times we talk about, uh, you know,
I think at the beginning of the course you saw something around three circles, right?
So product management is kind of the intersection of, you know,
the business, um, kind of like the design piece and also the technology.
So a lot of this is how do we know that we've found something at that intersection,
so that on the side of the user,
you understand what it is that they're hoping,
uh, to accomplish, on the side of technology,
we believe that there's an opportunity,
and on the side of the business similarly to- uh,
technology, we believe that there's opportunity.
We're running a deep dive in a minute,
after we've introduced the formula to know the life cycle,
unlocked every step but you spent a lot of time talking about this particular job.
Yeah. And the reason we do that is because if you can get anything right,
it's this- this part because it is the foundation for everything
else in the product life cycle and also the easiest thing to actually screw up.
The second phase, um, is- okay,
once you have a problem,
how do you actually decide what it is that you need to build to solve that problem.
So we call this designing your solution.
Um, we will talk in our class but not in this webinar about,
uh, what we call the design a framework,
where you essentially really co- diverge in terms of brainstorming different ideas,
thinking through what the right design constraints are in order for
you to constrain the infinite ideas that you could have.
And then really start to converge, right?
So you know, "Hey,
what shall I actually put aside?
How do I protect this cheaply?"
And use my project to identify whether or not I built the most,
um, the cheapest MVP.
So minimal- Minimum Viable Product,
in order to solve that problem.
Yeah. And one of the things, again,
we spend a lot of time around the course is, um,
for projects to have sufficient complexity and there's usually
a very large possible number of ways you could solve the problem.
So how do you get the balance right between exploring all the ways to solve the problems,
which will take infinite time or will be very expensive,
and making sure that you're building the best possible thing?
Yeah. And we also talk a lot about,
how do you know that prototype that you've built is actually good enough,
passes enough of the quality bar where you
actually understand that it's something that people would use.
All right. The next phase,
and it's really much tied to what Anand was saying earlier
around shipping is a big part of what you have to do.
The next phase is building, right?
So once you know what solution you should build,
you actually need to be able to guide to your team,
um, in order to build it.
And so as a product manager,
what's interesting is, um,
you actually don't have any direct lines of reporting- reporting typically on the team,
so your engineers report to an engineering manager,
you're designer re- will report to a design manager.
How do you actually motivate them and help them get to a building a product that really,
really works and it's beautiful, right?
And so in- in this section we essentially talk about,
uh, that iteration of taking something that's a prototype,
being able to get to the point where it is
hardened enough for it to be shipped to the world,
and all of the phases in terms of
getting- getting that feedback from the different user groups.
All right. The next phase,
um, is actually shipping it out to the world.
And so the part here that's important to know is that just because you built a product,
it doesn't mean that everyone in the world is gonna start using it.
And so it's- it's actually really important to understand how people start to,
um, learn about your product like a marketing perspective?
How will they start to,
um, use your product?
How will they start to pay for your product?
And so history is really littered with lots of examples,
where even though someone built an amazing product,
it doesn't mean that that led to them winning of the market.
And so in our course, we talk a lot about what are the strategies that you can
deploy to make sure that you are shipping and marching in a way that,
um, is thoughtful about gaining market share. Anything to add?
No.
All right. The next phase is measuring.
So essentially, you have launched it to the world.
How do you start to understand through data
that you're actually solving a problem that set out to solve?
And so this is really around, um, you know,
getting the right information and where to get
the next phase of this- by my example, which is iteration.
And so yeah, this is the last piece.
How do you start to iterate and create a real feedback what we're taking the
both of quantitative and the qualitative data that you're learning about your product,
and feed it back into an actual roadmap where you were able to say,
"Hey, this is where we are today.
This is where we need to go.
Going back to the concept of vision and the end state.
Here's how we're going to keep iterating,
keep measuring, um, to get there."
And I think what's really important to point out is,
what we've just laid out for you in terms of product life cycle,
is this constant iterative loop,
where you're gonna be running this over and over again as you work on
V2 of your product or even just a feature that's added to the product that you designed.
Cool. So last thing to stress,
this is not a waterfall process.
Um, I think you- you probably have heard this terminology before,
you know, agile versus waterfall, all of that.
The most important thing to remember is that if going to details
on these definitions is it needs to be iterative,
where your constantly collecting feedback,
you're constantly challenging your assumptions,
and you always have in mind what is it- what is it that you're trying to test.
And so it is not something where it's a straight line from the beginning to
the end. All right.
So again, I think to kind of like turn that into a picture,
it is a loop where essentially designing and testing constantly.
Um, and just like an onset at the beginning,
this is something that should be pretty familiar to a lot of you.
I think when we were in elementary school, we learned about, you know,
the scientific method where you have a hypothesis and test it.
And so really that's what this is,
how do you actually create a process where you start with, um, a hypothesis,
how do you start to test in an unbiased way,
how do you have the right guide for some manual process,
and then feed that back in to whatever it is you're
doing so that you're learning, um, as you're iterating.
Okay. So do you see,
we gave you an overview of, um,
the product life cycle or at least our understanding of it.
And we want you just today is spend a little bit more time talking about
the first piece of the product life cycle which is all about evaluating opportunities.
And again, the reason that we wanted to start with this one is
it is the foundation of getting there- everything else right.
I very much think that this is a cumulative process where
every step is dependent on getting the previous steps correct.
If you get in the first step wrong,
we can almost guarantee you're not building the right thing.
Um, in my career,
this is actually been the number one cause that's, you know,
the thing going wrong, where you don't have
agreement ahead of the time on what you're actually trying to accomplish.
You get three quarters of the way through building
the thing and you realize that you either or not
solving a real problem from
a customer perspective or the company doesn't have line of what you're trying to do.
First, start of in the beginning and how do you
evaluate an opportunity and what is that actually.
And an important precursor to evaluating
opportunity is really important to have some definition of success.
And this is something that ultimately ends with being
personal for you as well as personal for the company.
Um, it is okay to not wanna start a startup,
it's okay to not wanna have a billion dollar company.
It is totally fine to say my definition of success is I
wish I created a product that generated
passive income so I could spend more time with my family.
Um, this is something that we just wanna emphasize because there's a lot in the media,
in particular, about pushing you towards
that particular path saying path x is better than path y.
And our take on this is very much personal, um,
it's all about knowing what success look
like and being intellectually honest with yourself.
Um, but one of the things we've seen be really
important is you have to define success up front.
Um, as a product manager sitting in a corporate environment,
you need to agree on,
for example, uh, what the metrics are that matters to the company,
and what's more important first,
and what's less important.
And is success look like changing this by
10 percent or success have to be changing it by 500 percent.
If you don't know those things ahead of time,
it's going to be impossible for you to figure out what you're trying to accomplish.
Let's talk about the difference between a problem and an opportunity.
And we use the word, uh, intentionally and differentiate between them.
Our view is that an opportunity is an idea that has been
validated to be good for both the user and good for the company,
and it's important to be at the intersection of those things.
For the visual people,
we'll put this up on a slide,
where you want to be in the middle.
Um, I have a couple of interesting examples that you can
illustrate being on one side of the spectrum versus the other.
Um, I don't know how many people in the audience are
familiar with the recent spread out MoviePass.
Um, MoviePass was a huge hit where we live.
Um, the MoviePass was a subscription where for $10 a month,
you could see as many movies as you wanted.
And one of the interesting things with it,
a single movie in San Francisco will probably cost something like $15- $20.
So for the price of less than one movie,
you could see as many movies as you want.
So think about this as, good for the user verses good for the company.
This is a great product.
Um, they had astronomical growth,
er, they had tremendous word-of-mouth.
They got hundreds of thousands of people who signed up for their product.
The problem was, they lost money on every single person.
Like they've done something like build a product that was amazing for the user,
but was too far to the left on the side of this spectrum.
Um, for those of you in the audience who are familiar with
Napster from like 1999-2000 era,
very similar across the problem.
Napster was an amazing product from user's perspective.
Infinite free music, it turned out to not be a very good business to run.
Uh, so that's an example of how you could be too far to the left.
Um, I think one of these- my personally
favorite examples of being too far to the right is,
uh, my Internet provider happens to be Comcast.
Um, for those of you who have sort of experienced Comcast in your life, uh, I'm sorry.
Um, and they tend to be really frustrating from
a customer experience perspective and from usefulness perspective.
You really wanna be in the middle.
Like the whole point of this,
and the difference between a problem and opportunity is,
if you go and talk to a bunch of people in hear problem back from them,
it is possible to solve that problem and still not build
a successful product because you're not able to
capture any of the value for the problem that you generate.
So today we're not focused on business models,
we're not focused on pricing and packaging,
we at least wanna flag up front that you must be thoughtful,
not just about solving customer problems,
you have to believe there is someway for you and your company to capture value.
And I would say that a lot of times at a larger company,
it's almost easier to lean on the side of fit for company as opposed to good for user.
And so, it's really,
really important in my mind to actually able to articulate,
what is the problem that you're solving for?
You just start there and then say,
"Okay, we can't end there."
We are to then to say, what is good for company?
what's the opportunity that Anand was talking about?
To get to this happy, middle ground,
kind of the intersection in the same diagram.
Yep. So again, let's talk about what it means to be the, uh, for, excuse me.
What does it mean to be good for the user, it's pretty simple.
I mean, these people love their thing.
Um, favorite examples of this are, er,
every time Nintendo launches a new product,
or Apple launches new product,
people line up outside of the stores at
midnight and camp out and wait to buy their things.
That's what you want, right? It's very clear that you're
generating some real value from a customer perspective,
if people are demonstrating that sort of behavior.
And again, what it means to be good for the companies that you
capture some meaningful value from solving the problem.
And the emphasis- and there kind of a lot of different ways you can do this.
Um, you can try and capture a little bit of value from very large number of customers,
or very large number of transactions,
and Amazon again, is a great example here.
Um, they have very low margins,
but they sell so much volume,
they are able to capture a very meaningful value.
Um, you can also be on the other end of the spectrum.
Er, you could be more like Oracle and more like Workday.
They have a very small number of customers.
If you capture it potentially tens of billions or hundreds of millions of dollars,
and that is a lot of them.
There are a lots of ways to build a successful business on top of this, and in the class,
we spent some time talking about
some differences between the two models that we just talked about.
But fundamentally, your job as a product manager is to
make sure that you start with a customer problem,
and then you believe that you captured value from them.
We talked a bit about the difference in a problem and an opportunity.
Hopefully, you should at least have a loose sense at
this point what it means for somebody in an opportunity.
Now, let's talk a little bit about problem definition.
Um, and one of the really common things we is,
er, you start off by talking to your customer.
Uh, a product manager goes out in the field,
they spend a bunch of time talking to customers,
the customer asks- asked for XYZ thing,
and the product manager says, "Great."
They go back to their team and they say, "We should build this."
Um, your fundamental job as a product manager, often is to translate,
I want blank for my customer and it is something that may not be that.
The problem with this approach is,
that it's fundamentally flawed and it really can
replace two key concepts that we wanna talk about today,
the problem space and the solution space.
Um, there are many,
many examples from both our careers as well as from history where,
you go talk to a customer,
they tell you exactly what they want,
and build that thing, and it does nothing.
And fundamentally what you're doing in this world,
is that you're delegating product management to your customers,
and they're not professionals in this job.
Um, there's a little bit of a trope here,
that I wanna be careful about.
Um, there's an apocryphal quo- quote that
Henry Ford maybe said and the jury's still out.
Um, "If I'd asked people what they wanted,
they would have said faster horses" and of course,
he's famous for producing the first mass produced car, the Model-T.
What we're not saying here is,
don't listen to your customers.
What we're saying is that, your job is to take
a stated solution that a customer gives you,
translate that back into a problem,
and then re-figure out the right way to solve that problem.
And the framework there that we use for talking about this is called the,
problem space and the solution space.
And again, these are absolutely key concepts for product management,
and really the heart of what we wanted to speak about here today.
The problem space is all about where you talk about,
what problem you're solving for the customer,
and has nothing to do with how you are going to
solve that problem, entirely solution agnostic.
The solutions space on the other hand,
requires a prerequisite understanding of
a problem space and it's all where you talk about, how to solve that problem.
And we will walk through a little bit more detail hoping to make it real.
Um, when a- let's take the Henry Ford example.
Um, if Henry Ford had gone to a customer and said, "What do you want?"
And they said a faster horse,
what a customer is pitching as a solution.
They are pitching a solution to an unstated problem,
which is, I wish it took less time to get from point A to point B.
Your job as the product manager is to hear the words faster horse,
and internalize it, actually what they were wishing for is a different transit method.
The problem space has no solutions allowed.
We're not buying that faster anything,
better anything, uh, how to do anything different,
your only job is to understand what your customers believe and feel today.
It's very much you read all these mode of listening to your customers.
A huge thing to emphasize is about,
understanding reality for your customers even if they can't articulate it well and,
even if it's not objectively true.
I have definitely ran into multiple scenarios in my career
where a customer believes something that is not correct.
Um, they believe a product doesn't have a certain feature,
or that it can't do something else.
It doesn't matter. This is not the point to pitch them on it, or sell them on it.
Your job here is to listen and understand
what they believe and understand what they feel,
and then figure out later how to solve it.
The solution space is where you start to
introduce the notion of how we are going to solve the problem.
And again, the model that we keep coming back to is,
you must talk to your customers in your beginning.
Your customers will model these two concepts, your job is to,
is to distill out of those conversations the exact problem and then,
retranslate it to a solution.
Er, so another way of thinking about this is,
the problem space is entirely defined by our customer.
You have zero input here,
and zero right to comment on it.
But the solution space should be defined by you.
And if you draw the clean distinction between them,
it means that your customers are not doing your product management,
and you're not, er, sort of crossing the net and feeling alive on your customer.
We know a lot of this can sound fairly abstract,
so we wanna to have JZ walk through an example,
that will make this very real, very perfect for you.
All right, okay.
So imagine that you're in a world where
your success criteria is actually to reduce the carbon footprint of commuting to work.
And so you decided, "Hey,
I'm gonna start a business,
something that will take me longer than 50 hours a week,
and I'm really gonna focus on this problem,
specifically, how do I reduce the carbon footprint."
And from there you are like, hey, you know what?
One way to do it is, less cars, more bikes, right?
So you have this concept in your head,
but what's most important is,
you pause there, you actually go and talk to your users.
So in this example,
you say to yourself, "Okay,
I'm going to find what my target customer actually is." This is really important.
You need to actually to go out and say,
"I am going to focus on these people,
and not these people."
So you're, you're gonna go out and say,
"I'm gonna focus on people who bike,
but I'm not gonna focus on the people who take public transport,
for example, you know, take the subway or take the BART or the Muni, or whatever that is."
So this is important because,
if you define your target user and anyone who might- going back to the previous slide,
be part of the- the,
you know, solution in reducing the carbon footprint,
you could be talking to a lot of people,
and you need to be able to prioritize your time,
and- and who you're designing for.
So, okay. Let's stay on this case, your are like, "All right,
my current customer is just- just the people who bike.
Let me go talk to them and let me hear what it is that they are struggling with."
And so you go out there, and you hear a bunch of statements that sound a lot like,
what Anand was just saying,
where solutions that the customers think they want something,
and they're telling you what they think they want feels.
So you go there- you go out there and you basically hear,
one, "I wish I had an electric bike.
Hills are terrible and electric bikes would really help me."
The second thing hear is, "You know,
I really wish I had a better helmet because it, it- they're so expensive".
Um, you know, "If had a better helmet, cheaper,
I would just feel much more comfortable biking
and therefore I can help you to reduce the carbon footprint."
The last one is, "Okay, I don't bike a lot.
You know, I really wish we could fix the roads.
The road quality is really like terrible.
So you know, if you did that,
then I will be comfortable biking."
So let's say these are the three buckets of things that you're hearing from your user,
when you go out there to ask them,
why do you not bike as much as you could be biking?
Or like, what could we do to help you bike more?
So it's pretty easy.
Well, a lot of times your product managers can hear this
and they think that translates into a solution thing they feel.
So in the first case, you are like,
oh, someone wants an electric bike.
If only I could give them a cheap,
usable electric bike, maybe they will actually bike where there are hills.
Um, you might, in the case of, you know,
the next line, for the better helmet,
you're like, "I just need to make,
uh, a, you know, you know, safer one,
a less expensive one,
and I give that to them, they will start biking more.
But this is kind of the big fallacy that we were just talking about before,
if you just listen to what they said they wanted,
and then you built it for them,
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're solving the crux their problem,
or why they're truly not biking in the first place.
So let's assume that you're in a situation and you dig a level deeper.
So instead of just hearing what they said and doing it,
you start to try to understand,
why is it that they are claiming that they want a certain situation?
And instead, you find out something pretty different than your first reaction.
So in the case of the person who is saying,
"Well, I really wish I had an electric bike."
What they are really upset about and what caused them to not
want to bike is that, because there are hills, by the time they bike into work,
they are essentially super sweaty and they, you know,
don't have a way to essentially go from that mode
into [LAUGHTER] into like a clean mode where they can go in to work.
And so you actually learn from that user that they like biking,
um, they get exercise from biking.
But because they get so sweaty from all of that biking,
they are reluctant to actually bike.
So that's a fundamentally different problem than,
"Hey, give me an electric bike?"
In fact, if you build an electric bike for that person,
you might actually find that there- they
crave the exercise they used to be getting when they were biking.
Um, so that's- that's why it's so important to actually
understand why they're asking for the things they are asking for.
And the second case, um,
you actually learn that the reason [NOISE] why someone wants
a better helmet is because they're super afraid of getting hit by a car.
So in their mind one of the best ways to kind of guarantee that is, you know,
protection and protection to them
translates- translates into helmets as opposed to anything else.
And finally, just to go through these examples,
in the last case that a person who might be really worried about road quality
at first is actually truly worried about falling.
They're worried that with the roads the way they are,
they're gonna go through the bumps and end up falling.
So [NOISE] if you
actually understand the second level of what it is that they are struggling with,
you might have a very different solution.
So the solution that you would land on instead in the case of, "Hey, you know,
I really feel like I want to
exercise," but you realize that what they're actually saying is,
"I want a way to not be super sweaty when I get to work."
Your solution there could actually be building showers at work.
Fundamentally, different solution than giving them electric bikes.
In the second user's scenario, um,
where they're asking for a better helmet but
their real problem is that they're afraid of getting hit by a car,
you know, a helmet is a reactive thing,
it's like after you get hit by a car how do we make sure that you are,
you know, not as hurt as you could have been.
Instead the right solution could be to build
protective bike lanes where cars can't go into those bike lanes and hit the biker.
And then finally, in the case of the person who's really worried of falling,
instead of just fixing the roads for them,
a much cheaper thing to do would be providing them with a,
um, providing them with a bike with better suspension.
You know, think about how much that cost versus having to repave all your roads,
that solution is gonna be much more
sustainable and directly solve the problem that that user is facing.
We wanted to walk through these examples to just try and make this a little bit real,
we know the- the fire slides could be abstract.
So hopefully that gives you some idea of what we wanted to talk about today.
And again, we cover a lot of this in the class and I think Pax mention in a couple minutes.
Really our goal is to get to a place where
these people who take the course feel like they're capable and qualified
to either be better product managers if they are already product managers
today or confident that they have the knowledge they need to break into the field.
So with that I think we'll turn it back over to Pax,
um, Pax wanna take it away.
So with that, I want to move into some Q&A.
Um, we have been getting really a lot of excellent questions,
Anand and JZ and kind of looking through them
there are three basic, uh, categories.
So I think the first one building off
of what we were just talking about in terms of the course there are questions around,
how do you become a product manager?
Um, and so maybe just starting there,
what would you- if you're say for instance a- a enterprise solution business analyst,
we have a very specific example and you are interested in
making that transition into being a product manager,
uh, what advice would you have?
Um, my experience is that the unfortunate reality
is that the best predictor of getting
a product management job is already having a product management job.
Um, having said that though there are like three or call it
common tasks that probably make up 75 or 80 percent of the people that I see.
Um, one of them tends to be more of an option for I say junior people,
um, which is like a structured training and development program.
Um, Google is famous for its APM program,
Yahoo has one, Microsoft has one,
Facebook has one, Dropbox has one.
So there's a whole set of companies that actually have
a structured program that
will take people who do not have a product management background,
teach them the skills usually in the order of about two years.
Um, and then they're either rotated throughout
the company or they get a job somewhere else.
Um, that is a- usually a good career options for people who are early in their careers
or people who are transitioning like another way I see that
happen a lot is somebody ends up at business school,
then they end up doing a rotational program.
Um, but if you are later in your career,
it obviously has some costs associated with it,
it may not be something you wouldn't wanna do.
That's option one that I've seen a lot.
Option two that I've seen is have
some fundamental knowledge about your customers that is being used for the
product management and the two really common teams that I see transition the most
often from an internal transfer perspective are something around like customer success,
customer support, and something around sales.
And the reason that both of those are true is because both of those jobs
fundamentally require you to have a very strong understanding of your customers.
What those people can often bring especially in
larger organizations is less of the knowledge about
product management and discipline but
a very high level of knowledge about your customers.
And you sort of have this interesting pair where
they'll often get paired with a peer mentor,
that mentor teaches that person product management skills
that person makes sure that they have to call a customer.
So if you're interested in that route,
obviously it depends on your company and a bunch of other things.
Um, but making sure that you represent
a very strong voice of the customer and find for them what is important.
Um the last one is a- it's a more of a Silicon Valley option.
So I recognize this is not necessarily ideal for everyone.
So a lot of people who end up as product managers actually
started companies that either were successful or were not successful.
Um, it's pretty common in my experience at least in the places that we've worked where
founders of companies end up in product management whether it's through acquisitions,
whether it's through a failed company or the next job.
Um, I'm definitely not advocating that you start a failed company rather than a PM job,
that's not the most efficient path to get in there.
But those 3 categories probably make
up 80 percent of the people that I know in product management.
Yeah, and just two things to add.
So I know that, you know,
you've mentioned you are business,
um, you know, analyst, a solution analyst.
I think that having- in that role,
you actually gain a lot of knowledge around the actual product,
like you are actually going in there and you're saying, "Hey,
in order for us to deploy or this innovation to work like these things need to happen."
And so that kinda fits into the second one,
um, that Anand was describing.
And I'd say that the last one it's not just about founding a company,
and you can also join a startup, right?
And at a startup, it's- there's always
too many jobs for the number of people who are there,
and so you get to wear a lot of different hats.
And in that case, you can wear the hat of being an engineer but
at the same time wear the product hat because you're essentially, you know,
in a company where there aren't product managers and you as an engineer needs to decide,
you know, what is the problem and how do you actually implement it?
And so that's another option which is not quite the be
a founder path but go to a startup and wear a lot of different hats there.
And then fun fact,
how did- how did you,
uh, solve transition too?
Sure, uh, the way I actually ended up in product management was I
worked at a startup as an engineer
and doing like chemical engineering and process engineering,
and I got to pick my title and I just picked product manager arbitrarily.
[NOISE] And when I interviewed at my next role,
they said we see you have product management experience. And I said yes.
Um, so I'm probably the- the living example of how not to do it.
Um, but that was a total case where the best predictor
of a product management job was already having a product management job.
That was great, um, I wanna build on something you said a Anand.
So you- you said that you see a lot of people transit-
transitioning from customer success and sales positions.
I think there's sometimes a perception that you need to have
a strong technical background to be a successful product manager.
Do you have any reflections on that?
What level of technical expertise is that going to depend on
the- the product or the company or- [OVERLAPPING] Ye yeah.
It is going to depend on a bunch of things for sure.
Um, like if, uh,
the probability of you transitioning to be an infrastructure PM,
um, is probably not super high if you were in customer support right now.
So it's a little bit role dependent.
But the way I thought about this previously and
actually for people that I've hired is what's
not actually important is some notion of a degree or explicit credentials in that thing.
You don't need need a CS degree, you don't need, um,
what's much more important is that you
have a detailed understanding of how the product works.
And if it's a software product,
kind of something fundamental about how computers work.
There are many, many ways to get that.
Some of the best PMs I know actually did not have
formal computer science training but spend a lot of the time when
they were 17 to 22 like
building stuff and taking things apart and putting them back together,
in many, many ways to get that knowledge.
And one of the things I see people
overemphasize is like the signaling value of that knowledge,
whether it's trying to get experience or something else,
in my experience it has been much more important to be
credible for the team that is responsible for building the thing.
And that is really the bar. There are many ways to accomplish
that whether cheap or less time than are required.
One other thing to add there is,
um, there are different types of PM roles, right?
So you can be a role PM,
you can be more of a generalist PM,
you can be a PM for a lot of, you know,
ML like work, you can be a platform PM,
you can be an infrastructure PM.
And for each of those roles, um, you know,
the amount of experience or technical expertise is gonna be different.
So when I look for,
you know, ML PMs, um,
having some kind of background in data, um,
having that experience and that technical acumen is
actually pretty important because a lot of it is independent on the fact that,
um, you know- you've done this before.
If you are a zero to one PM, like a generalist PM,
like actually having a really great sense of
structured thinking when breaking down problems is the most important thing.
And so it really depends on what it is the company needs,
what is it the product needs,
for that particular area, you know,
what is the match between the background and the need.
And then fun fact, I was an econ major but in the past few years of my career,
so I built, you know, zero to one products but right now, I lead infrastructure.
So it's a- it's a very different world.
The- the fluidity of being able to apply some like broad principles to, um,
very technical areas or vice versa,
being able to bring some of that techni- technical acumen
to a growth area is actually very interesting.
So that's a great segue, uh,
building on that where do you see the role of a class
like yours or a shorter class or webinars?
If you're trying to become a product manager,
where do you- what is the value, uh, in that?
So, um, the first piece of value is I think
that a lot of people actually don't know what the product management job is, um,
I- the number one request I actually get from students is,
can we get a coffee and you tell me what your day is like.
Um, it is different at every company and a lot of variation among it.
But one of the things we actually spent time on early in the class like what is your job?
How are you measured, what does success looks like what is the role and
I've actually seen a non-trivial number of people
who thought they were interested in product management,
and actually were interested in something else.
Um so being one that I think that were help before
is if you're not sure you're interested or you're not really sure what the role is.
We will tell you what the role is.
At least getting you an accurate.
If you want to spend time on this. Uh but the second part like
what do people get out of it uh my experience has
been it's much easier to learn where you have some framework
that you can build on top of and fill with examples than anything else.
And really what I think the course offers is a structured way
to think about problems that very few companies teach.
Uh most places do not have a program to teach
you Product Management. It is mostly learned on the job.
So if you have some framework and you end up and you're able to transition to the
role what it does is let you get much better at your job much faster.
If you like know how to fix things at the bottom pattern
it's like you know the difference between a problem and solution
space that alone will save you 500 hours of 5- 500 hours of point right.
There's a lot of things that sound like they are small or
sound like they're obvious that you can then had- you
can build experience and depth on what you need to have
is some framework to hang that experience on top of.
I think that's really what we provide is some notion of how to think about the arc of
the product management role as well as what the framework looks like to everybody in the class.
That's great uh, you raise the issue and so now I'm going to ask the question.
You talked about it a little bit and it sounds like the class is very focused on this.
So it's a bigger question than we have time to fully answer.
But we have gotten a lot of questions about defining that role of
product manager and so let me give you a few here to kind of make it more specific.
Do you see the product manager who's kind of a facilitator you know connecting
all these different pieces or are they someone
who takes ownership of the product design and then leaves the effort?
Where do you see them in that spectrum and I-I know it will depend
on the company but if you can give us some of your insight into that or your experiences.
Yeah the people I know who are best at their job,
are perceived as facilitators but are actually decision makers.
I think that's like that is sort of like the key skill that is required.
JZ mentioned this earlier.
You don't have a lot of explicit power like you are
not anybody- usually you are not anybody's direct manager.
Your team is usually small or is besides another team
like explicit power in another way that PM's tend to get duties done.
But people tend to listen to you if they think you're right.
So ultimately the PM job for me concerns to guiding your organization to
the correct set of to accomplish
whatever they want right focusing on the aspect of the customers.
In an organization where you have
all the right ideas and what's missing is like execution or coordination.
You can take on a facilitator role in an organization
where what's missing is the important ideas but there are very good at execution.
You tend to be much more at a decision making role.
So I would - I would honestly think about the role of
the outcome backwards instead of skill set forward is
all by getting outcomes that we talked about in the webinar and the ways you get there
will depend not just on your company but on your team and even the people on your team.
Like if you have a world-class engineering manager who is flawless in
execution you should stop spending all of
your time on execution by spending the time on everything else.
So it's a very very fluid and requires a little bit of being good at
almost every part of like their life cycle section that we talked about.
But I would actively think about changing your role almost on a month month
a quarter quarter basis based on whatever is
needed to get the outcome like find the outcome and work backwards.
Yeah I say that being a chameleon is important able to have
the EQ right to essentially evaluate the situation and be like this is what most needed for my team.
We talk a lot about some core principles.
We didn't go into in this Webinar in terms of one of
the big things that you do besides kind of what Anand mentioned earlier.
In terms of What are the principles that you kind of do everyday.
We talked a lot in the class about how your goals as CEO but you're also a janitor at
the same time which means you know if there are
things that need to be cleaned up it's your job to clean it up.
Ideally you find someone but like at the end of the day the outcome is what is important.
So whether you're flexing between cleaning things or setting
the direction with the CEO role like that's something you decide.
It's also really important that you-you are the facilitator of
communication so we talk a lot about what's interesting to make it and.
How do you become that kind of like a
hub-and-spoke where you're essentially able to connect all of these different functions
in the organization whether it's legal or marketing or
all these other roles that need to come together to ship your product correctly.
I think something that is very unique about
the role other roles there's some director level or is uniquely outcome focused.
That means I don't really care how you get there the job is to get there and you need to
diagnose whatever needs are-are necessary from an organizational perspective this is really fascinating.
This is the reason that a lot of like CEOs
end up coming out of product manager because it's very outcome oriented.
You usually don't have that transition here and say
you're pretty senior like directors VPs are equally
responsible for the outcomes over the company level uh but in
most organizations you have
at least 15 or 20 years in your career to follow that route through.
Product Management is one of the few exceptions to that and that's
the reason it ends up being a training ground for so many leaders that are executives.
Because early in your career you figure out what it means to own outcomes instead of owning a process.
That's fantastic um sort of
trying keeping a little bit on defining the role we're moving into.
A lot of the practical questions we got kind of day-to-day product management questions.
One person asked that product management seems to be very focused on
launching existing ideas or products or sort of incremental features.
How do you recommend that PM's think about the future is that something that is also part
of your wheelhouse or is that something that is being decided at a higher level.
Yeah.
And if so how do you bring that into
your conversation as you focus on the outcomes that are desired.
That's a great question um I think there are two different things
that I think about one of them is like where are you in your career?
If you have been a product manager
for a year and a half chances are you're thinking about
very large macro things are pretty low usually you are
focused on the next thing next week next month.
And then you get more senior you actually end up more unto the ladder.
The way that we strike a balance between them is a big part of my job as the VP of
product management a pilot is make sure we have
the right balance of short-term versus long-term staff.
There's very much like a-a failure mode of
product management organizations where you
believe that the next feature is a magical thing right?
This is the thing that works whatever we're
trying to accomplish and more often than not it's not true.
So we actually have in our roadmap setting process a process that
I run where you sort of classify everything into small local optimizers and
global optimizers. The local optimizers are like
Here's the set of- here's the product we have today.
We can do a bunch of stuff only 10 at percent better, 20 percent better,
50 percent better, but cumulatively in five years,
we want to be a 1,000 percent better.
We need to make some bigger bets,
on things that we believe will fundamentally change our products like 2_x or by 5_x.
They tend to be more expensive and they tend to be much riskier.
But I'm really looking for is like a risk-blended portfolio,
where I know that we have a set of
small things that I know we're going to do deliver short-term result,
instead of bigger things that actually may or may not deliver long-term outcomes.
But my job is to be the key of the organization,
to make sure we're both thinking the same.
And do you think that,
at all times, your company,
your team, your organization, whatever it is,
should have a long-term view on what it- what it is it's trying to accomplish?
And a lot of the PM role is actually translating, uh,
wait, connecting the dots between all the different levels.
So we talked about company mobile vision.
We talked about, you know, what does that mean then
for like major initiative across company,
I mean, how, how does that translate into actual, you know, teams?
And so your job, as a PM is to break that down.
So you should have a, you know,
a year-long road map that that then nests into
the other thing the company is doing so that at in any given point someone could say,
look, all of these things are happening and they will
come together to get the company from here to here.
And so having a long vision is very important.
It does depend on the type of work you're doing.
If you are a growth PM,
it's actually totally fine that you don't have a road map for more than three months out.
Because quite honestly, you're learning every single thing in terms of,
you know, AB testing, iteration.
You're gonna learn a lot of things now that invalidate
or validate things that you do the next three months out.
But if you're for example, platform PM,
you better have an eighteen month road map because you
need to understand how am I gonna built something where,
if I do this, the company will be
accelerated in the following way because of a platform like this.
And so it really depends like the,
the time horizon that you think out to,
depends on the goal and kind of work the company is meets that role.
You find horizon depends on the product. Like a product manager
at Boeing probably has a four year or five years time horizon, right?
Growth Product Manager at Facebook has like a 36 hour timeline.
It's like very dependent on the type of thing you're doing.
[LAUGHTER] That's great.
Ah, so related to that, um,
as you look at in your making these, these plans,
how do you strike the balance between analysis and decisiveness, right?
What do- what advice would you have for
a Product Manager or a product team that's facing analysis
paralysis, or is moving too fast to actually analyze anything? If that makes sense.
Yeah, got it.
So wha- what I usually say to my teams is,
always have a hypothesis and a framework for what
you're testing so you can actually say, okay.
Of course in that framework,
this is what I learned,
and this is what I'm wrong on,
and this is what I wanna keep testing on.
And so if you don't have a framework like that,
it's really easy to go like down the rabbit hole.
Where you just like, oh, crap.
Like, should I keep testing this area?
Like, I'm kind of paralyzed.
Right. So most importantly, have a framework.
Um, I think in general,
this is said for lots of industries which is like the 80/20 rule that applies here.
How do you actually use,
ah, you know, data, kind of,
kind of like qualitative and quantitative data
that you have in order to make some important decisions?
And even when it comes to,
you know, talking to our users,
instead of talking to a thousand of people, you actually,
usually get what you would get with hundreds of people by just talking to 10 people.
Right. So is the 80/20 rule applied in
all things whether it's learning about your problems,
talking to users, or making decisions on like, 80 test.
Yeah, I had two things that I say a lot to my team.
One of them is, what is the cost of being wrong?
The second one is, notice when you're confused.
The thing that I seen actually really killer in
very large organizations is that everyone's confused.
It's not that they're- it's not that very fundamentally wrong about what they wanna do,
it's that everyone thinks you're solving a
slightly different problem or doing slightly different things.
You just like diffuse and end up doing nothing.
Right. Um, confusion is a huge killer right now.
Instead, ah, it's like pretty difficulty at a hundred people doing the same thing.
So as you get larger, you end up having primarily coordination problems,
to some extent all your problems are actually inside the building.
Second one, what's the cost of being wrong?
Like, and it's the question I asked a lot in product use, product review.
If you have some idea for something you wanna try and
the cost of being wrong is like a day of engineering, right?
Great, no need to wait anymore, go for it.
Seems fine, right? But if- again, let's talk,
let's talk about the space shuttle or like an airplane or a bridge, right.
If the cost of being wrong is very very large whether it's human life,
whether it's large dollar cost or about something else, then you better be right.
So I think a lot about the, the,
cost of being wrong, and like the downside of failure relative to the investment.
And then I really want you both to notice when the organization is confused,
and then we push towards decisiveness.
Yeah. One principle that's related to that that's easy for people to
visualize is a concept of a one-way door, right.
So like, you know,
if you are actually going through a door,
what's really hard to kind of back out off,
be very thoughtful about that decision but if you're like, look,
I can keep trying it and work that quickly, that's totally fine.
That's fantastic. We're, we're nearing the end of our time here.
So I think maybe we have time for one more quick question,
um, and then we'll, we'll wrap up.
So another question that came up several times is,
a lot of product teams can have a hard time saying,
no, saying no to engineering, saying no to the CEO.
So how do you- especially coming back to your earlier point that you don't
always have decision-making authority within the context of the larger company,
how do you say no?
I mean, negotiate that.
Yeah, you know, it is your job as PM to say no,
but I think the point of this question is how do you say no gracefully?
And a tip that I usually give my teams is this concept of, yes and.
Otherwise known as provide options.
And what that really means is, hey, look.
You know, I understand the spirit
of what you're asking for. That's actually really important.
A lot of times people going back to, you know,
users being confused, CEOs can be confused,
people in the company can be confused.
They can be like, I want this to happen,
but really what they're hoping for is something else.
Right. Or like I understand the spirit of what it is that needs to happen.
Translate that into a problem statement and then say,
here are the options that we could go through and provide.
We can do A, B,
and C. Here is the pros and cons of each one and I,
as the subject matter expert,
now in your area, really recommend option B for these reasons.
And so being able to provide that kind of, like, options space,
and really have it be backed up by data,
is really really helpful when having this conversation.
The other thing that works very well for me is not to say,
no, but to say, later.
And what's fascinating is like how many organizational problems sort themselves out,
waiting to say, later, and it never comes back.
Um, the pattern that I think we
actually end up building are things that, that keep coming back.
Right. Like, if we say later and then a month ending here, and then a month later,
and then like, it kind of a keeps coming out, then,
yeah, probably a good change we're going to work on it.
But you'd be surprised how many things just go away if you, yes.
But later, I mean, will never occur.
Okay. Well, ah, thank you very much.
Ah, until later but hopefully in the classroom.
Ah, so we wanna thank you both for your time.
That was really a, a fantastic presentation.
I wanna thank everyone who attended and for your questions and your feedback,
we really appreciate it.
Again, if you're interested more from Anand and JZ,
there's an opportunity to take a class with them,
uh, this winter quarter.
I encourage you to check it out.
And if not, hopefully we'll see you again in some other form,
either on a webinar or in a self-paced short-course offering.
So [OVERLAPPING] thank you again.
Thank you Anand and JZ.
Thank you everyone for joining. And thank you Pax.